bei Annalena baerbox Besuch im Peking
passieren zwei Dinge die erstaunlich
sind zum einen eine Konfrontation auf
offener Bühne bei der sich Chinas
Außenminister chingang genervt
Lehrmeister aus dem Westen verbittert
und bärburg China vor einem Angriff auf
Taiwan warnt
noch erstaunlicher ist was Peking danach
macht nichts keine propagandatiraden wie
sonst so oft Peking schweigt es muss
sich nicht streiten andere in
Deutschland in Europa übernehmen das
Frankreichs Präsident Emanuel macron
etwa der bei seinem pekingbesuch erklärt
Taiwan das sei nicht unsere Krise das
glatte Gegenteil zur Position der EU und
zu bärbock doch macron bekommt
Unterstützung ausgerechnet von bärbox
Koalitionspartner
dass wir aber nicht gleichzeitig in ein
großmachtkonflikt zwischen den USA und
China kommen das finde ich schon eine
berechtigte Frage über die wir offen
auch diskutieren sollten und
zumindestens hier nicht ein
empörungsritual wieder Folgen wie tief
in Berlin der ampelkonflikt zu China
geht zeigt sich auch daran die AFD sieht
die Sache ähnlich wie Mütze nicht
kritisiert wie er die Außenministerin
damit hat sie uns und der deutschen
Sache gar kein Gefallen getan und davon
mal ganz abgesehen sollten wir uns nicht
in anderer Länder Konflikte einmischen
taiwan ist nicht unsere Frage und liegt
auch nicht im Interesse unseres Landes
und dort Einzelmengen
Taiwans Vertreter in Deutschland ist
alarmiert will Europa sich etwa
raushalten Peking würde das zu einem
Angriff möglicherweise noch ermutigen
China ist wichtig das ist ohne Frage
aber ohne Tay One ist man den
persönlichen Glück von China aus
ausgeliefert und ich glaube langfristig
gesehen oder kokosfüße gesehen wird dann
die deutschen dann erpressball
erpressbar zu sein von China das
fürchten sie auch im Auswärtigen Amt
eine China Strategie soll helfen die
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten zu
verringern ein vertraulicher Entwurf vom
November zeichnet China als Risiko Land
vor dem sich Deutschland wappnen muss
man stehe in einem systemwettbewerb mit
China das Land wolle die regelbasierte
internationale Ordnung verändern zu
Deutschlands Nachteil
im Hintergrund haben Diplomaten und
ampelpolitiker in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder versichert bei dem
Strategiepapier soll sich die Koalition
einig oder war sie es nur
just zu Bernburg pekingbesuch lanciert
der Seeheimer Kreis der konservative
Flügel der SPD ein gegen Papier er
fordert eine kohärente China Strategie
dafür keine antichina Strategie sein die
die Entkopplung Deutschlands von China
als Ziel verfolge
[Musik]
das Spiel China in die Händen das ist
genau was China möchte ein gespaltenes
Europa
was Sie nicht möchten ist eine Europa
die diese diese Differenzen beseitigt
wie gravierend der Konflikt und die
china-strategie ist zeigt sich auch
daran wie sehr die ampelkoalitionäre auf
den jeweils anderen zeigen diese
Differenz ist natürlich auch gerade von
der Außenministerin der vorgerufen
worden und das sind Dinge Differenzen
die natürlich auch in Peking sehr
wahrgenommen werden den kann ich in
außenpolitischen Fragen wirklich nicht
ernst nehmen das der Klingbeil und der
Olaf Scholz so eine Essens Geduld mit
ihm haben ist ja vielleicht für das
innerparteiliche Klima der SPD ganz gut
aber ich glaube
das ist nicht die Richtung der Ampel wer
mag sucht heute in Japan bei den G7
weiter nach einer gemeinsamen
china-position in all der Uneinigkeit
darf China sich freuen das eine seiner
alten Weisheiten weiter gilt der klügste
Krieger ist der der niemals kämpfen muss
und beim Treffen der G7 Außenminister
und von dort ist sie uns auch
zugeschaltet ich grüße Sie Frau bärbock
hallo schönen guten Abend Frau baerbock
sie haben China öffentlich kritisiert
und Teilen der SPD ihres
Koalitionspartners ist das deutlich zu
weit gegangen haben Sie denn die
Rückendeckung des Kanzlers
also ehrlich gesagt bin ich hier jetzt
seit einigen Tagen nicht nur in China
unterwegs sondern in Südkorea und jetzt
gerade beim G7 Außenminister treffen
angekommen und deswegen weiß ich nicht
was jetzt Teile der SPD alle einzelnen
Passagen kritisch finden sondern hier
war sehr sehr deutlich geworden sowohl
in Südkorea als auch beim g7-treffen
dass alle mir gesagt haben wie wichtig
es ist dass wir diese gemeinsame
europäische Stimme die Frau von der
Leyen als kommissionspräsidentin ja
schon eine vorgegeben hatte deutlich zu
machen wir wollen keine Entkopplung von
China weil China ist unser größter
Handelspartner aber wir müssen unsere
Risiken minimieren wir müssen die
risking betreiben weil wir auch
wirtschaftliche Sicherheit brauchen wir
können die Fehler der Abhängigkeiten von
Russland nicht noch mal wiederholen und
so wie mein chinesischer Außenminister
Kollege deutlich gemacht hat sie wollen
wirtschaftliche Sicherheit für den
chinesischen Markt aber ich deutlich
gemacht und wir brauchen wirtschaftliche
Sicherheit für unseren Markt und da neue
zusammenarbeiten können und wollen da
sollten wir zusammenarbeiten aber wir
sollten nicht naiv sein und ausblenden
dass China sich in den letzten Jahren
verändert hat und ganz bewusst weltweit
Investitionen und auch seine
Wirtschaftspolitik für die eigenen
nationalen Interessen einsetzt und
gerade auch die Unternehmen mit denen
ich in China gesprochen haben die machen
deutlich wie wichtig es für sie ist dass
wir als Bundesrepublik als Europäische
Union für Rechtssicherheit für die
deutsche und europäische Wirtschaft
sorgen Frau bärbox sie haben da eben von
einer gemeinsamen Haltung gesprochen
aber ihnen wird auch in der Entfernung
nicht entgangen sein dass es eben Kritik
gegeben hat von ihrem Koalitionspartner
und die SPD steht ja auch nicht alleine
damit auch immer nur im macron hat ja
mit seinem besuchen mit seinen
Äußerungen danach eine Haltung markiert
die eben nicht die gemeinsame
europäische Linie in allen Punkten
vertritt wo ist denn da die Einigkeit
und die Geschlossenheit
wissen sie dass sich wirklich anders und
wie gesagt ich saß ja gerade mit meiner
französischen Kollegen mit meinem
amerikanischen Kollegen mit ihrem
panischen Kollegen italienischen
Kollegen britischen Kollegen und der
Kanadierin hier zusammen bei unserem G7
treffen und wir alle haben hier noch mal
deutlich unterstrichen und auch der
französische Präsident ja nach seiner
Rückkehr in Paris wir brauchen eine
wirtschaftliche Sicherheitspolitik als
Europäer und als G7 Staaten und diese
Linie hat auch der Kanzler ja bei seinem
Besuch hier in Peking bzw in China
vorgegeben als er eben da auch in seiner
Pressekonferenz deutlich gemacht hat wir
wollen die europäische Linie Partner
Wettbewerber und systemischer Rivale
gemeinsam hier als Europäer vertreten er
hat auch die Menschenrechte angesprochen
hat auch angesprochen wie wichtig die
freie Fahrt in der Straße von Taiwan ist
und genau das habe ich auch vor Ort
getan weil wir haben im letzten Jahr auf
brutale Art und Weise gesehen
was passiert wenn wir glauben Handel
allein sei schon eine Strategie das war
das leider nicht sie haben und wir
mussten dafür ein wahnsinnig hohen Preis
bezahlen wirtschaftlich und politisch
und dieser Fehler darf uns nicht noch
mal wiederholen wieder fahren und
deswegen haben wir als Europäische Union
dieses gemeinsame China Verständnis was
hier unterschiedliche Partner vor
deutlich gemacht haben Frau Werbung sie
haben gerade Taiwan angesprochen und die
Risiken die damit einhergehen haben Sie
denn sie waren gerade bei einem
Abendessen im gemeinsamen mit ihren G7
außenministerkollegen haben Sie denn
einmal darüber gesprochen welche
konkreten Beistand Taiwan von den G7
Staaten erwarten kann im Ernstfall
wir haben gemeinsam hier deutlich
gemacht so wie ich das auch in China
deutlich gemacht hat wie Frau von der
Leyen das deutlich gemacht hat wie der
französische Präsident das deutlich
gemacht hat dass durch die Straße von
Taiwan 50 Prozent des Welthandels gehen
und damit sollte es dort zu einer
militärischen Eskalation kommen die
ganze Welt betroffen wäre deswegen ist
es in unserem aller Interesse und
darüber haben wir heute beim Abendessen
gesprochen zu verhindern dass es zu
dieser militärischen Eskalation kommt
letzte Frage mit der bitte um kurze
Antwort wenn es Ihnen nicht gelingt die
Eskalation des Konfliktes zu verhindern
welche konkrete Unterstützung kann dann
Taiwan von den G7 Staaten erwarten
wie gesagt uns geht es darum dass wir
deeskalieren und deswegen ist jetzt ein
spekulieren über was wäre wenn das
falsche aber man muss auch deutlich
machen dass wir es nicht hinnehmen
würden wenn es zu einer militärischen
Eskalation kommt und das gute ist ja
hier dass wir zum Beispiel auch mit
Amerika zusammensitzen dass wir
gemeinsam darüber gesprochen haben wie
wichtig auch dialogformate zwischen
China und den USA sind der amerikanische
Außenminister hatte ja eigentlich
angekündigt nach dem letzten G20-Treffen
auch mit seinem chinesischen counterpaar
zusammenzutreffen nach China zu reisen
dann hat es allerdings diesen
ballonvorfall von chinesischer Seite
gegeben das heißt ein Treffen stand kurz
bevor und dieses Treffen das wäre aus
meiner Sicht wichtig dass es dieses
Treffen zeitnah gibt das habe ich in
China deutlich gemacht und das habe ich
auch heute Abend deutlich gemacht sagt
die deutsche Außenministerin am Rande
ihres Treffens mit ihren G7 Kollegen
herzlichen Dank Frau Bock
danke ebenso alles Gute